[Applause]
[Applause]
basically this furniture guy that is
going around this country like a jersey
this one can this be betting flip a coin
both of them article that's not true I
just need look here's geared up and
ready to go how much is here's enough
all right ready to go you wanna pen
I didn't see more yeah what's the moment
I wasn't over odor on us oh my god I'm
gonna say it's a family you have 10 you
don't know well there's no 6 in half
like is that 8 and a half I got the
other thinking about it
are you guys trying to wreck this idea
got that under six and a half likes hey
mr. Mack this is Sam Richard from
Bleacher Report how you done I just want
to say you're a legend and your story is
incredible and really resonating with
our audience over here at BR and a
couple of us are actually trying to make
it to Houston if the Astros make the
World Series I should say when the
Astros make the World Series and we'd
love we'd actually love to kind of spend
some time with you and share your story
if you have any availability kind of a
round game Game one in Game two just be
a few of us probably like two or three
we honestly would love to kind of follow
you around that whole day come to your
store and everything what how does that
sound to you yeah I know yeah I can't
kinda four chickens for the house you
got my number to contact adopted awesome
thank you so much I can't wait yeah have
a good night thank you let's oh I
thought he was gonna be like I'll give
you five minutes we're actually gonna
watch the game with him holy I don't
think you said like once yeah I tell my
fiance why did you say it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ashley's lunch last night and I am
pretty sure you're going to find Matthew
smack I'm jacked up we doing this I'll
do this plane tickets brother let's get
on it yeah we rose rose rose rose rose
rose oversight cheese mattress back
we'll do it that will clarify the stock
Bob that's a free drink tickets three
highly Astros got high in the bar coats
and all silver our wedding [ __ ] I
don't happy with my two best friends my
two co-best men of my wedding yeah she
ever shirt on is not no shirt
[Music]
I love you
I said I don't know this were saying
like are you near here where where did
you want to meet he goes yes I live
right over there just call I'll meet
y'all
or pick y'all up this is 9:10 right now
the day before the world security
I ain't got a whole lot of money riding
on this series that's why I've been the
bottom many many times I've been to
Mississippi Mississippi strange man up
took up three point three million dollar
master bathroom win the World Series get
back seven point seven million profit so
that'll cover a lot of mashed
[Music]
- eyebrows go here is in the Las Vegas
review-journal there's a picture of ugly
me doing a betting slip and thing closes
this morning my phone number two eight
one eight four four one nine six please
call me if your illegal bookmaking more
action on these I think I have a high
[Music]
and we literally cannot walk anywhere
because Mac is getting stopped every
five hundreds of fans and five minutes
what Mac say to us about his experience
last year at the World Series
you could not make it to his feet and
that is increasingly becoming over now
and by the second we have a literally
not moved more than 10 steps and 15
minutes it is just absolute
madness
yeah Louie will we get there get me
started about half hour yeah well we get
there who knows
[Music]
in the look of a man that has to pay for
beer
[Applause]
[Music]
boys as Mikey boys up in that
[Music]
I'm back up I been with the goal I just
be mrs. got my job at Joseph's
intelligence in my judo
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing
alright take all my eggs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
great experience we're devastated
Castro's lost but at the same time
because incredible season 167 within
three things when officers so god bless
trust it was a great promotion a lot of
fun problems
god bless the extras and needs
[Music]
returned